hello everyone
i'm kristy jewell of labyrinth and i
would like to welcome you to today's
event
our webinar is titled how multiplex
imaging reveals key insights into the
tumor microenvironment
to inform treatment and improve outcomes
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinths and brought to
you by sciteba
saitiva is a global provider of
technologies and services
that advance and accelerate the
development and manufacture therapeutics
formerly part of ge healthcare life
sciences they have a rich heritage
tracing back hundreds of years
and a fresh beginning since 2020. to
learn more about our sponsor
please click on the saitiba logo on the
left side of your screen
or visit saitiva lifesciences.com
now let's get started so today's event
is interactive and i would like to
encourage you to participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
your questions will be answered at the
end of the presentation
also please notice you can share this
webinar on your personal social media
just click on the social sharing tab to
let your friends and colleagues know
about today's live event
now if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation click on that
support tab found at the top
right of your presentation window or use
that ask a question box
to let us know you're experiencing a
problem today's presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
your presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i would now like to pass it over to your
moderator paul goodwin
welcome paul the floor is yours
christy thank you very much for your
introduction i'm looking forward to
telling you about our multiplex imaging
and the role and
understanding the tissue micro
environment
i'm paul goodwin as christie introduced
i'll be talking about the resurgence of
multiple
immunohistochemistry and a bit of the
history of the field
i'll be followed by dr fiona gente who
we talked who is a researcher and
technical manager
uh in biosciences at the ge research
center
should be telling us about cell dive
imaging a decade of research validation
and translation
and then we'll be followed by prachip
ghetto uh
prachi is a diagnostic segment leader
and marketing leader for cell analysis
within saltiva
and she'll be talking to us about the
cell dive imaging advancing cancer
research and care
i'd like to start us off by looking at
the history and
resurgence of multiplex
immunohistochemistry
and to me the story starts with cancer
if you think of cancer
and i know for a long time i was locked
in my career thinking of cancer as a
disease of genetics in the cell cycle
but that's part of the story so as cells
are exposed to the environment they have
a genetic history
and the age of the individual you
accumulate a series of mitotic
necessarily a series of genetic defects
in the cells
this leads to loss of control of mitosis
which then uh means that checkpoints the
proofreading of the
genome gets skipped which leads to more
genetic instability which leads to more
mutations which leads to
more skipping etc but that's only part
of the story
uh that leads to unchecked cell growth
the other part of cancer is a loss of
identity
so cells live within an environment and
they
they understand who they are and what
they are what they're supposed to be
doing because of the environment
around them if they lose their ability
to sense that environment and interact
with that
with other cells in that environment
again because of the cells themselves
their environment or the age they then
lose their identity and they don't think
they no longer belong where they are
and so they'll go walk about we call
that
metastasis and those cells will go and
try to find a new environment where they
feel more at home
which can lead to more disruption of
their sensing of the environment
which leads to more mito metastasis etc
so if we want to understand uh
immunocollage here the interaction of
the immune system
and cancer we have to realize that
cancer is not just a genetic disease
um there also is a wide and meaningful
dynamic range for many structures and
objects
that are important for understanding the
interaction of not only the genetic
defects within the cells but also their
interaction of the environment so it's
not enough to know that how many cells i
have per area
i also may need to know the intensity uh
or the mass of staining per area
there are also many many different
components within the tissue and within
the cells i need to understand
and it also is very important by the
anatomical context the sense of place
is really critical to understanding
what's going on in the tumor and just
knowing what cells are there through
looking at transcriptomics or binding
and grinding and measuring protein
concentrations
is insufficient to fully understand the
tumor
so if i want to make a system that will
allow me to study that complex micro
environment
i need a system that's both sensitive
that is it has a
very high signal to noise ratio it's
specific
that is i can identify the
specific signals i'm interested in
measuring and dissociate them from the
background and from non
non-specific interactions they need to
have a dynamic range
one and zero is not sufficient i need a
range
and that range needs to be linear linear
so i can trust it
i also need to look at many many factors
in the same sample
and serial sectioning is usually
insufficient because of the size of the
cells that we're looking at and the size
of the structures
we're trying to identify as i said the
anatomical context is essential if
possible we'd love to be able to do this
non-destructively
to leave open the opportunity for coming
back and studying
either the sequence or or rna
transcripts within the sample i'm
looking at
this is what i was talking about earlier
the challenges of studying immuno
oncology
and this is a cartoon by drew but we can
see here within the sample this is
supposed to represent a microscope
field of view and maybe i have a blood
vessel here in red
uh to the right of that i have a large
green cell there's our tumor cell
if you notice that a little brown cells
next to that those may be represent
immune cells which are a fraction of the
size of the cancer cell
in many cases there are also other
things in the environment
stromal cells or cells that describe
just the structure
of the tissue in which the cell the
tumor lives
there also are proteins and other
microstructures
that all interact with the tumor cell to
define this environment
and then go about defining this exact
tumor
why i want to better understand it so
how do biologists understand this kind
of environment today
historically the microscope was invented
in 17th century and we had the ability
to start looking at things that were
smaller than we could see with our naked
eye
but if you just look at a piece of
tissue and so the left hand side here we
see
a section of mouse lung that is
just thinly sliced and put on the micro
microscope slide you
see it's very difficult to see any
structure to see any cells of that
but fortunately the earlier
microscopists were also very much
involved
with the textile industry and some of
the first things they did was they took
textile dyes
things that they would use to stain
fabric blue or pink
and they applied those to the microscope
slide and suddenly structure became
apparent
and so in the slide on the right we can
see the pink
which is stained with eosin and purple
dots which are the nuclei of the cells
that stay in the nucleus and that that
science is called histochemistry
we can go further beyond the
histochemistry and here we have again a
piece of a mouse lung uh generally
generously provided to us by dr charles
freeber at the university of washington
and so we have general histochemical
standing on the left but
with koontz in 1945 and years later
developed the ability to look for very
specific molecules
within that tissue so we see brown
staining here with a
so-called dab reaction in this case
identifying the very specific
molecule uh highly highlighted neuron
and so we can get very specific
molecules with immunohistic chemistry
the problem with that kind of
immunohistochemistry is we're limited to
the number of things we can look at at
the same time
so here's a two color it's actually rna
fluorescence in situ hybridization
but you can see there's a little there's
a blue labeling in the
in the stain with uh with the arrow on
some of the arrows and we can also see
red staining with some of the other
arrows
and the background of purple and so
you're trying to see pink and
blue and purple all on top of each other
and so that limits our ability to see
staining with chromogenic
but if we look on the other side we can
see with fluorescence we can see more
colors
so here we have on the right we have a
wrap eyelets
in the pancreas in blue we see the
nuclei of these cells
and then we see staining in red which is
glucagon
in the alpha cells that surround the
eyelid and then we see
staining in green which is against
insulin which identifies the beta cells
within the eyelid
and if we look at these colors
independently we can see
that it's very easy for us to dissociate
and to understand where the nuclei
are where the glucagon standing cells
are and with the insulin staining cells
but sometimes this few colors here here
we have three labels
sometimes that's not enough and you can
see if we want to understand the complex
environment
of uh of a tumor that we need much more
than three stains
and so over the years a number of
techniques have been developed
from chromogenic immunohistochemistry
and fluorescence immunistic chemistry
which we just saw
to multi-spectral imaging to spectral
mixing
serial multiplexing and many other
techniques
and today we're going to look at one of
these in depth called serial
multiplexing
and with that i'm going to turn the mic
over to doctor fiona genti
hi hi everybody this is s the only
guinty uh thanks paul for the
great introduction on the history of
immunohistochemistry and a nice lead
into
the work that i'm about to present uh
for the next 30 minutes or so
on what we've done over the last uh 10
over over 10 years actually
at the ge global research center in uh
niskayuna in new york
so i'm going to uh just give you a sort
of a step back in history but also
start with where we are today in terms
of spatial
cell biology and the sort of importance
that sort of bear in mind some of you
are new to this some of
some of you are are studying this for
some time now but um
really spatial cell biology is opening
up new insights into health and disease
as regards looking at diseases at a
single cell level
really allows us to understand how and
why
disease uh progress and gives us new
insights into heterogeneity into the
types of cell types involved the immune
cells
the different functionalities of those
cells and the microenvironment and the
stroma
around those cells and and potentially
the crosstalk between those two
uh environments and so with that with
that new level of understanding by
understanding where the cells are
located how they're interacting with
each other
we can begin to now chip away at
understanding disease mechanisms
um immune response spatial cell
interactions and hopefully that leads us
towards
new ways to diagnose disease in the
future
now when we started this work um over 10
years ago
we really started with a blank slate and
at the time thought really deeply about
why we wanted to go into
um pathology and we as ge is a
destroyed history and in medical imaging
looked at what we had done in radiology
and that transition from
um analog to digital uh in radiology
and saw really an opportunity in the
pathology space for
making that transition to to digitize
images and potential value of that and
there were other companies working at
that at the time but we saw the
key opportunities around speed um
usability for the
for the pathologists and then the
content within the image
what else other than the h e features
that are so
um close to the to the pathologist
workflow today how could we
expand that information uh to be more
protein
focused and cellular focused so we
started this brand new program
back in 2006. many of us most of us in
fact had never worked in pathology or
oncology before
but in a sense that was a good way to
start because we all
came at the problem with the new with a
new unique mindset and how we might
solve
this problem but this also precipitated
our
interactions with academia pharma and
clinical end users because
we knew from them that we would need to
know exactly what their workflows
are what their problems were today and
how we could solve
together with them so over the next
20 minutes or so i'll tell you more
about how we
went through that path but just to sort
of shortcut it to the end
you know we fast forward uh you know 10
years and we
you know in that time we transitioned we
developed our workflows we optimized
them we transferred it to
clients and neogenomics as the
multiomics
technology and that was offered as a
service and then
uh two years ago we started working more
closely with our
sativa um collaborate um
partners rather and uh formerly
key life sciences and then allowed us to
deploy the system
out to prototype of prototypes out to
our collaborators
and this really gave us the hands-on and
knowledge that we needed
to gather to to proceed um to what is
now today the commercial launch of zelda
which we're all very proud of
so just to get into the to the details
and then we can talk a little bit more
about the collaborations
but essentially this is a initiative
staining method we use
immunofluorescence
we developed a method by which we could
do an antigen retrieval
one time at the beginning of the process
a lot of work went into the imaging
and i'll talk a bit about that as well
but knowing you know these
samples because we're in fluorescence
imaging we have background so we had to
consider that that autofluorescence
signal
and we image the sample after staining
we de-stain it and then we do a cycle of
30 to 40 cycles for 60 plus
biomarkers and that gives us this very
deep
and you can see as i'm going through the
slides here uh
this very rich data set which um
can then lead you into a process by
which you can analyze all of these
biomarkers
at a single cell level and then
spatially because the coordinates for
every cell is conserved
and in each of the in each of the images
that are taken
so then we here we see an example from
our publication that we
had it back in 2013 in the pnas
where we show this montage of 43
different proteins
in colorectal cancer and this was our
first big publication
which we you know worked very hard at
for several years to make sure we had
covered
all the bases and all the um different
aspects of the workflow so that we
weren't just at that point
presenting a set of images we also
presented comparisons to
and some ground truths we worked for
memorial sloan kettering which i'll show
you in
shortly and then devise methods by which
the images could be registered the
autofluorescence subtracted
and then um cells could be segmented and
then we could
quantify it at a single biomarker level
so this whole workflow you know took
several years really to figure out and
develop into a
highly automated workflow where images
could be processed as they were being
collected which is their
sort of standard today as the images are
being
um as the samples are being imaged they
are automatically being registered
waterforest and subtracted and um
[Music]
they are you know it's something that's
done while you're imaging rather than
waiting to the end
of the process so then when you're
finished your whole experiment you have
a registered
af removed a authorized removed set of
images for the number of biomarkers that
you've studied
and so with that you know we had the
next challenge was really the
uh reducing these millions of data
points because as you know
in one field of view you have perhaps 3
000 cells depending on the cancer type
now scale that to 50 100 patients if
you're working with tmas or if you're
working with whole tissue sections
uh you now are in a sphere of millions
and
and even close to a billion data points
and
depending on how many biomarkers so we
developed a lot of different workflows
which we've published on over the years
on
looking at you know biomarker
correlations um
assuming you know certain biomarkers
should be co-expressed then we should
see these in these types of correlation
plots
that we generate and the darker the the
circle here being the stronger the
association between those markers
we developed some nice workflows for
clustering different types of
cells depending on their biomarker
expression and then working with our
collaborators we translated all of that
workflow
to real life examples and in this
example i'll talk about again later in
dr carcinoma
in situ you can see where we look at
both the lesion area
which is colored in brown it's a very
homogeneous
group of cells as opposed to the patient
below it which is more heterogeneous
there's more
colors present and you also see
interestingly in this particular patient
the same sample a lot of immune cells
around the outside of the lesion
and on the patient below that less
immune cell so we're actually
doing a larger study on this at the
moment with indiana university
so then with that you know you really
open up the door once you've
got your workflows down you're confident
about the reproducibility
uh you have the antibody validation
which is another huge part of what we
we've done over the last 10 years you
can really start to
think about where single cell analysis
makes sense and we have done
studies in immuno phenotyping we've
looked at the single
signaling pathway heterogeneity this is
also part of the pnas paper
and then we've also more recently
started working in neurology
and applying the same workflows
now with all of that of course we have
to consider
the the hardware itself and so a key key
part of what we've done
over the last um 10 years is really
ensuring that the quality of the images
is consistent there's a calibration
workflow that we put in place to ensure
that the
um systems are can be compared to each
other the data output can be
compared to each other and this was
carried forward over the last 10 years
when we
implemented the workflow at neogenomics
these calibrations were also put in
place
and so it's just been a hallmark of of
our workflow
and ensures really the quality of the
data um
at the at the end of a study and allows
it to be comparable
to to other subsequent data sets in the
future
now just so that we can um sort of
not uh certainly take credit for all of
the work that we did we our team is a
multi-disciplinary team we
we're really you know as an amazing team
to work with over the last decade we're
we're comprised of biologists and
chemists and engineers and computer
vision scientists and statisticians and
physicists and and and you name it um
but we
you know the beauty of this team was
that we were able to work closely with
uh these collaborators um and i'm just
going to mention a few today
um but i'll uh briefly talk about
what we did with each of them and how we
learned from them we listened to them we
learned from them
and then how in turn we uh deployed uh
those workflows into
into what is uh cell dive today so
i'll talk a little bit about memorial
zone kettering
uh cancer center fantastic collaborators
uh eli lilly
um pharmaceutical company and then our
various
nih programs which we um
are awards that we we achieved in
collaboration with with several
different collaborators across the u.s
and internationally as well
so really uh i'll start with memorial uh
sloan kettering
cancer center or mskcc um
we really worked with them from day one
um on
back in in 2006 we were really learning
from scratch
about the pathology space and you know
spent many days down in their pathology
um uh the department watching them
watching the pathologist
watching the workflows understanding
what could be changed and
what could not be changed within the
standard
i mean history chemistry workflow um two
key things
that we learned during this time and we
started with breast cancer because that
was
one uh area where we you know they were
they were well
documented well uh reported markers
eastern receptor for two staining
that have you know are widely used and
diagnosed with today so that gave us our
ground truth
on which we started to compare a lot of
our
assays and our assay performance um
we also then once we had some confidence
in
and the performance of our antibodies
and our workflows we then started to get
more complicated and
they had some very nice rna expression
data sets
uh that we that they wanted to compare
our workflows to so that's sort of
another
important point in any new technology
for those of you
already working in this type of field is
you know comparing back to the
previous days or the earlier data and
and proving that either you get the same
results
or equivocal or or new finding is
but certainly step one is to prove that
you compare
to what's been done before an
alternative method
and another key learning from this
period was in working with the
pathologists there
was the need for a something that was
familiar to them so this
virtual h e we we developed so we
converted
the grayscale images to what looks like
an h e and you can see that here in the
uh
in the in the in the figure shown on the
right that pink
image is created from that brown
grayscale
image um so those are the two sort of
key things of many many learnings as
well but
just that brown truth and and the
reference
uh image that familiarity to to the
pathologist was very important
and then once we you know we've worked
with msk for for a few years at that
point then as i said we started to get
more complex and there they um
proposed that we do an rna expression
uh comparison study where we they
already knew
the results they knew in this case the
correlation with ftg
uptake and they wanted to prove that we
could find the same correlation and in
fact we did
and um we also showed um not
surprisingly and you can see in these
smaller images from the publication
uh with uh dr engel mellinghoff and
these are
overlaid pie charts or clusters of cells
and the more color
they're more uh black color so in here
you see yellow
more yellow that's more homogeneous is
more of that type of cluster cluster
eight
and whereas on the figure on the left we
see much more heterogeneity
more uh colors in each of the pie charts
and so this was really the sort of the
start of of our work and
of others in looking and thinking about
heterogeneity and how that um relates to
two outcomes now in parallel with that
we also knew that we needed to
understand the
pharmaceutical workflow and here we
worked with eli lilly
again for about five years in fact we
worked with them on cell lines
pre-clinical
samples clinical samples from multiple
sites so looking at that cross-site
variability and then also looking at
larger retrospective cohorts with
recurrence and outcome data so that gave
us
a new understanding of data size
big data comparisons uh with across
groups stratification and we developed
all of our
statistical workflows in in r which are
still used today
and we share readily with our
collaborators but here we also looked at
antibody validation
this was of course a very key uh
theme that carried all the way through
all of our collaborations
and having a really well characterized
workflow which i'll talk about in the
next slide
another thing that we learned with eli
lilly is you know as we went from you
know in our early days we were just
working on one microscope
and now the need grew to go to multiple
microscopes so we set up a lab with 10
microscopes and they're inlaid the
challenge for calibration
for um cross comparison of data
slot quality control slides controlled
slides
and etc study design and so we really
for a few years with eli lilly and with
our other collaborators really focused
on our statistical
workflows our normalization and again
that sort of led to where we are today
in terms of when we publish papers we
always describe our workflow
and uh um you know share our experiences
on that
um on that sort of scaling from one
microscope
to multiple microscopes and here on the
right is just some of the work that we
uh published with eli lilly that they
were very interested in
um blood vessel development and uh we
looked at
many different markers related to early
stage blood vessel maturation
late stage blood vessel maturation and
the interaction with the immuno
profiling
um we really as i said focus on antibody
validation workflow and this is just
where i want to
emphasize for just just a moment that we
um you know
worked out this uh sort of very rigorous
uh workflow which we still use today um
at the time when we started to work with
eli lilly dr jeremy graf who we worked
with at the time
was extremely helpful and and rigorous
with us
in terms of advising of how best what
they would need from a pharma
direct perspective and this certainly
maps to every other collaborator
that we worked with since and and we
have hundreds of antibodies that we've
uh commercial antibodies that we've
validated
to this point where we do a direct
conjugation so we directly label those
antibodies with
with our dyes uh binding dyes or alexa
dies
and that in turn allows you to do this
high level of multiplexing so we do a
primary secondary
usually in the first round and then
follow that with
direct conjugates um for how many
however many rounds
are needed uh we also test the number of
dyes
to protein ratio we keep that consistent
we always
test from batch to batch variability so
a lot of really important
um um consistencies that are important
for your
you know follow repeating of your study
and uh
and those are implemented in the
protocols that are are
are shared today both in our
publications and as part of the cell
dive
package um so now i'll talk a little bit
um for the next
five minutes or so on a few different uh
um
our nih programs and this was really you
know a fantastic opportunity back in
2008 this was really
you know very very early days for single
cell analysis
and we were able to you know with the
nih you were
establishing a single cell analysis
program at the time
this gave uh you know really a huge head
start to the field
so we're always you know very thankful
to the nih for for that and then our
collaborators that we worked with at the
time
in particular we started with vanderbilt
university and we also worked with suny
albany
and dr bob coffey and his team we
we conducted work on single cell
analysis in colon cancer development
with that you know you sort of do you
either are many benefits
to to these types of relationships you
understand better what they need from a
research perspective in this case we
needed very precise
single cell segmentation because the
cells that we were looking at in colon
are very varied in their in their shape
and their size
and and no cell you do not want to leave
any cell
out of your analysis and this group were
very early adopter of the cell dive
prototype and they've been using it ever
since giving us great feedback
and then more recently they were one of
the five awardees of the human tumor
atlas
and so that was quite exciting to see
that progress you know from beginning to
where they are today
um in the last five years then um i've
also been pi
on um uh this work with indiana
university
and uh with dr sunil badzie and dr yes
and polar
and here we're looking at again taking
all of the the learnings that i've
explained
earlier around heterogeneity and
clustering
data analysis and looking at cellular
heterogeneity of dcis
lesions of structural carcinoma in situ
at the earliest stage
of breast cancer pre-invasive and here
we're looking at
20 to 30 different markers related to
both cell signaling as well as immune
response
we're looking at different ethnicities
we're comparing across
these different groups the expression of
these proteins
and how they differ in terms of outcome
we're right in the middle of analyzing
our outcome data at the moment
and that should be concluded this summer
but seeing very marked differences from
patient to patient
in immune response response so i think
this data that's going to be
you know quite exciting once we're
finished and we're publishing of course
all this work
another very more software-focused
project that we
we've been working with upit for for
many years
and um here we have been uh working with
lance taylor and and and um chocolatish
and about tabata
and uh in this case we have a had a very
uh sort of a different type of approach
here we we developed heterogeneity
algorithms which are actually available
on what we call the thrive website
and and this is related to the acronyms
related to tumor heterogeneity
and here we look at heterogeneity
spatial heterogeneity we continue some
of our work in colorectal cancer we're
able to carry some of these datasets
through
uh we have um shown in this in this
web-based
analysis that we can both conduct very
simple
um a single cell analysis as well as
the metrics for quantifying
heterogeneity and both these
uh work are published and we continue to
have a very good relationship
with a university of pittsburgh and that
team
now we of course mostly focused our work
around oncology to begin with
um and for still today but we did do
some very interesting work and this work
is led by dan meyer
dr dan meyer at the ge research center
and here he's extended cell dive
workflow to neuroscience
and taking many of the same concepts but
of course
neurology is a very different beast to
oncology
but looking at molecular diversity
cellular interactions
and microenvironmental factors in brain
and the underlying mechanisms
of neurodegeneration and he has also
been
the recipient of several awards from the
nih
working with ucsf and mount sinai and
boston university and so we've been
working for the last couple of years and
very large cohorts
that um have been provided by each of
these sites and looking at many of these
questions that are very sort of
carried through you know from disease to
disease and
heterogeneity cell to cells and
interaction is
is just now you know a very common theme
no matter
what type of disease state you're you're
working on
um and most recently uh this has been a
very exciting uh
new area for us we're working with the
hub map the nih
part of the nh commons fund and here
we're looking with a
large consortium where in our case we're
looking at
healthy tissue uh we're looking at
multi-scale 3d image analytics this is
led by um my colleague joseph
and and and anoopsood and here again
we're working with university of
pittsburgh in the dermatology department
and we're combining uh the multiplex
imaging serial multiplex
imaging of skin samples together with
micro ct
and seeing you know how we can combine
sort of a 3d reconstruction of these
multiplex images
together with a a validated if you like
3d imaging method microct and
i think you know what we're looking at
is you know once we've got that
3d reconstruction that analysis done
how do you look at changes um as a
function of aging and uv exposure look
at changes in
immune cells for example over time or in
relation to uv damaged
markers of dna damage um so this work is
is just in its first year and
uh it's it's a it's an exciting group to
be part of there's a lot of
other style atlas that's going on across
the u.s and around the world at the
moment
and um you know i think it's sort of
we're all learning together as well as
you know recognizing that there are many
commonalities across
both disease types organ and tissue
so just to my last slide um before i
transition over to
to perachy but um you know we're sort of
closed out here on
uh you know many years on foundation of
research of development of ideas and
concepts that we
implemented into software and workflows
and
2014 was was a landmark for us because
we at that point had
had confidence in the in the
standardization of our workflow we had
you know scaled the workflow the data
analytics the software
and so we worked them closely with
clarion um
to transition all of those workflows to
their
service lab and their own regulated
environment in 2014 and they then
and you know took it from there if you
like and they developed
a clinical laboratory improvement
amendment clea
assay for hodgkin lymphoma um
to publish that work showed that the
workflow
and multiplexing workflow single cell
multiplexing workflow
compared um extremely well with the
pathologist review of a single slide
analysis of hodgkin lymphoma
we also subsequent to that as i said
earlier we started to do
prototype deployment and we started with
sunnybrook
um health sciences central toronto and
vanderbilt et cetera and they all just
really provided us with
critical user needs uh calibration
automation and just troubleshooting in
general
and then uh 2017 2018 we started to
expand that out to other expert uh
collaboration sites and now we're here
today in 2020 and uh
commercializing uh the platform uh
together with uh sativa
and so i just want to close on on this
slide just to sort of remind
you of you know how we and we at the
beginning did not
know the space we did not fully
understand the space with scientists and
engineers but we
listened we learned we developed robust
protocols
we took all our feedback and turned it
into a a workflow that was
relevant and we focused on
disease-specific applications to
show the utility of what we were doing
and why and we just tried along the way
publish and continuously approve improve
our workflow so that they
stayed current with the times and stayed
relevant
um and so with that i'm happy to uh
transfer over to
uh karachi baguetto and
she'll tell you more about the saldive
imaging workflow
hi everybody i'm practical thank you
fiona for walking us through
all of the development that went into
the cell dive multiplex
imaging solution which is what i will be
talking about for the next 10 minutes or
so
so as we heard from paul we've seen a
resurgence in multiplex imaging
the real driver for that is the advent
of
immuno-oncology and therapies that
harness
a patient's immune system to fight
cancer
the imaging technologies we had in the
past do not provide rich enough
data to help us guide these therapies
for patients to better outcomes
but also to give us the information we
need about the immune system of patients
to develop better therapies in the
future
suppressive imaging as you see in the
traditional h e in this case is the
virtual h
e as fiona described gives us some very
rough
information first and most important is
this tissue cancerous or not
it gives us some information about the
types and number of cells
in the tumor and around the tumor but
what we really need is the
rich information that multiplex imaging
brings to diagnoses
such as what cell types are present what
is their biomarker expression profile
what's the nature and the extent of
vascularization within the tumor micro
environment what kind of cells are in
the tumor and around the tumor
and what are the specific immune cells
within the tumor this is the kind of
information that we need
to really harness the power of the
immune system
for therapies in cancer
at the top of this slide you see what is
a traditional
imaging workflow this happens to be a
bright field imaging workflow
which is typically limited to one or two
biomarkers per slide
and so what that compels the researcher
to do as you can see here
is to make serial sections and slides of
this one
precious piece of tissue since you can
only stain and visualize
at best too and usually one biomarker
per tissue slide
what multiplex imaging and specifically
cell guys multiplex imaging
brings to the table is the ability to
visualize 60-plus proteins
from the same tissue slice and leaving
it intact
for other investigations so as fiona
described it took
many many years to refine
both the staining and the imaging for
this particular technology
and we're pleased to talk you through a
little bit about
what it is and what is now available so
we introduce here
cell dive multiplex imaging solution
which is a
completely customizable multiplex
solution
that precisely maps up to more than 60
biomarkers
from just one tissue section with
resolution at a single cell level
when we say customizable what do we mean
you choose the assay panels you choose
which fire markers and how many you
would like to visualize
all of the work that you heard fiona
describe
in refining this technology comes
together to bring
extreme precision to all of the imaging
so we take
precision engineered hardware innovative
acquisition software
to give you precise imaging and
downstream
the capability to do single cell
analysis and as you know by now we've
spent
many many years refining all of these
technologies
so we can bring
reproducible reliable results
so what are the components of the cell
dive multiplex imaging system
he's taken all of the innovation in the
workflow
which fiona described and i will
describe a little bit later
and the acquisition software together
with a
vast list of validated commercially
available
antibodies and package them into a
license
the second component is the imager which
i'll discuss in detail later
and the third piece is analysis software
we chosen to partner with indica labs
and their software platform halo and
i'll talk a little bit in detail about
why we think
halo is the best choice to interpret the
results from this kind of imaging
so at a high level the cell dive
multiplexed
imaging solution workflow is displayed
on this slide
in terms of inputs you can input an
entire tissue slide
so the system is capable of handling the
standard tissue
size of a human biopsy you have the
option to choose within that whole piece
of tissue
individual regions of interest you can
also
input a tissue micro array
there are five steps to the imaging and
staining roms
you need the background autofluorescence
imaging
stain the sample image the sample
the system does the image processing and
alignment for you
you inactivate the die and this process
can be repeated as many times as you
need
for 60 plus biomarker visualization
downstream then you would analyze the
data and
interpret the results from your imaging
so at a high level
that's the workflow that's what enables
the imaging of 60 plus biomarkers
biomarker panel design so when we say
completely customizable that's really
what we mean
you choose the biomarkers you choose
which biomarkers
the cell diet solution includes a list
of thoughtfully curated
antibodies all of which are commercially
available
there are polyclonals monoclonals mouths
and humans antibodies that relate to
well-studied and understood disease
states and signaling pathways
including the most prevalent modalities
of cancer
and if this list doesn't include
antibodies
that pertain to your area of research
there is within the software a very
detailed
protocol to allow you to characterize
your own antibodies
so we provide you complete flexibility
in terms of panel design
let's get a little bit deeper into the
dye inactivation process that really
allows the
cyclical staining that leaves your
tissue intact
so the tissue is stained with dappy as a
nuclear stain this is what allows the
the image registration of serial images
and then up to four dye conjugated
antibodies at one time
the dyes themselves are inactivated to
turn off the dye molecules so the
samples are not damaged
and this is really what allows for the
cyclical nature of this staining
as you saw in some of the work fiona
presented the first patent for this
this uh serial staining and deactivation
was issued in 2009
it's been significantly refined since
then
so to image the slides that have been
stained with this process we've created
a purpose-built software suite
and really the goal is to make
multiplexing
seamless for the user the
software itself tracks every single
slide in the process so that allows you
to do
studies with a large number of slides it
allows you to do
different studies interrupting each
other without having to keep
track of which particular slide is where
in the workflow
within the software there's an automated
calibration routine so that allows you
to
correlate your data across multiple
slides
across multiple studies and across
multiple imagers should that be the case
all of the image processing and
alignment is
automated and refined and this is really
what enables
the downstream single cell analysis
the software is coupled with the imager
the imager is built on our in-cell
platform which
released in 2001 we are experts in
precision engineering and this system is
fast precise
and sensitive we made some improvements
to
um better facilitate
tissue imaging so the system is capable
of imaging
in five channels or wavelengths at the
same time
the barcode reader is integrated with
the system and with the software so this
is how you can track your slides
it's compatible with a slide handling
robot so
you can walk away while it does the
imaging the image processing and image
alignment
it has a large maximum imaging area
it can handle very large tissue
with absolutely no issues
the final component of the cell dive
multiplex imaging system is halo image
analysis software and we
chose halo for its ease of use and
scalability
the interface is very logical it's very
intuitive and what we really wanted to
do
is to bring the capability to analyze
these images
to people who may not have any
bioinformatics experience
we've worked with halo extensively
during our beta testing period
and we found their responsiveness and
user support to be
world class halo comes in different
modules with different licenses so you
can choose
what best suits your work
so here's just one example of how all of
these come together
all of these components come together to
provide the capability to do true single
cell analysis
so what you see here on the left is the
image of a tonsil tissue
that was part of a 30 marker cell dive
study here we've highlighted five of
those markers and as you progress from
left to right you can see
staining segmentation classification
and finally down to single cell analysis
of cellular phenotypes
this is just one of many examples of how
the cell dive imaging system
in all of its components comes together
to
bring you reliable reproducible results
none of this would have been possible
without the expertise
the innovation and the sheer persistence
of the ge research cell dive team
past and present we owe them a huge
thank you
without them we wouldn't be bringing
this capability to the market today
so we'd love to keep in touch with you
if you'd like more information
you can go to saitiva.com forward slash
cell dive
or drop us a note dot die
at syteva.com
thank you for your time and attention
today and um
we'd be happy to take questions
ask please do so now just click on the
ask a question box located in the far
left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
so let's get started
uh first of all i'd like to ask a doctor
ginty
does the order of antibody staining
affect the results
if i use an antibody in an earlier or
later staining cycle
does it make a difference
get here
um
thank you paul sorry we've had a couple
of uh
technical issues here with our mute
buttons i think that's
par for the course these days um yes the
um we do when when we uh validate our
antibody workflow there's a few things
to consider
in the um selection of position in the
multiplexing sequence
um there's an option to do primary
secondary uh staining in the very first
round so that's always a nice
uh option um if you want to do if you
don't have to go through the conjugation
process
and you can include your primary
secondaries in the first round
and there's also a second consideration
whether or not the antigen
is affected by the inactivation process
and that's part of our antibody
validation workflow that we test
the epitope and the staining the
sensitivity um
post uh sort of a pseudo
inactivation process and now if that
epitope is affected and we found about
10
of epitopes are and that epidural should
also be
our antibodies should also be placed up
front
and otherwise um what we've done over
the years is
singleplex versus multiplex and we have
not found the difference between
uh epitopes that are or staining
intensity for
for antibodies that are seen as part of
a multiplex sequence versus single flex
um i think that that's you know um
something that everyone should consider
as they design their
workflows and to compare their
individual antibodies and
back to singleplex staining um
but the two important considerations are
whether or not you want to do a primary
secondary
in your first round or uh
thank you very much uh this is a
question for
um for prachi
how long does it take to do a cycle of
imaging and staining
yeah that's a great question it's going
to really depend on how many markers you
want to do and how big
your imaging area or area of interest is
but if we take the example let's say you
want to do a whole slide
and you wanted to do 10 rounds of
multiplexing so that's
40 different biomarkers your time is
about
50 hours that's for staining and imaging
please keep in mind that with the robot
you can
image overnight so the hands-on time is
significantly lower than that
thank you dr genty uh
you have a question of is it possible to
combine multiplex
imaging of protein and rna for a more
comprehensive view of the cells or
tissues being studied
and it certainly is possible the only
consideration to bear in mind is
protease effects on your um on your
proteins so
what we would recommend is to uh test
that
pre the preparation protocol together
with the effects on your um your
proteins and some of our colleagues uh
former
colleagues at neogenomics have recently
shown the acd
combination of acd rna scope together
with
protein multiplexing in one of their
posters um so i think
it's possible but be aware of the
protein's effects on
on on your um on your proteins
great thank you uh i'm going to come
back to you again fiona on this one uh
people are asking the question is it
possible you describe the process
as being direct conjugated antibodies is
it possible to use secondaries or other
forms of amplification
to identify the presence of low
abundance proteins
yeah as i said in in my presentation in
a
few minutes ago the primary secondary
option is certainly available
for the first round of staining for
second round depending on how many
species
you have you want to obviously avoid
that cross reactivity
that is occurs with primary secondary
staining and that's
one of the reasons why direct
conjugation alleviates or works around
that issue
um so i think yes the answer is you can
use primary secondary staining
and then direct conjugation is then a
requirement obviously for your
for your later rounds
great um sorry to keep picking on you
fiona but a lot of people have questions
for your presentation
uh can you please comment on the
reproducibility of the assay
so if i were to repeat the assay
obviously you can't on that
probably can't on the same section but
in the same tumor
how reproducible is it yeah we've done
quite a number of different experiments
to evaluate that
pole so we've looked at sequential
sections we've looked at the correlation
between markers between sections granted
there is going to be slightly slight
variability which can be
in the order of depending on how
abundant your biomarker is you could see
a variation of maybe um from slide to
slide
maybe 10 to 20 variability anyway
because of differences in numbers of
slides of where you've cut into the
section
but overall uh we see a very high degree
of repeatability
um and that's helped for sure by the
calibration process
and the correction process that we use
consistently
for every study we do
great i'm getting several questions here
fiona about
the the principle behind the
inactivation of the die would you care
to comment on that
so the um when we looked at the
different methods of inactivation we
evaluated many different types
back in 2006 including stripping uh acid
um we've actually settled on
um an oxidation a mild oxidation process
knowing that cyanine dies have that
vulnerability
and really leveraged that as well as
alexa dies
and so we we are one of our scientists
and at the time
understanding the vulnerabilities of
these dyes took that to
our advantage in terms of the oxidation
process so the uh
we developed that we tested it over many
different
um um permutations
um ph is very important uh hydrogen
peroxide basic it's it's
a formulation that we um have uh
described in our publications as well as
is included
within the protocols um provided to
customers
and um i think the key thing is it was
sort of taking an advantage of a
weakness
within the diet that was um in terms of
its vulnerability to oxidation so the
thymine dies and the electrodives
uh fall within that criteria not every
dye is oxidizable um
in this in this regard so the fitzy for
example um
less so um although very light sensitive
and um yeah so hopefully that answers
that question
yeah thank you thank you approach a
question for you we're being asked about
the automation of the workflow what does
that look like
and how is that performed right so
um very briefly there are two
options to stain the slides depending on
your throughput and the level of
automation you'd like to have
the openwell cassette option
is compatible with pipetting robots
so you could automate the staining i
think most easily that way there are
other options with coverslips which
you can also set up but a little bit
chat a little more challenging a little
more work little more cost
so you can use a pipetting robot with
the open well
um cassette but the best use of
time that we've seen with our
collaborators is to do automated imaging
overnight
with a plate handling robot so the
slides image while you sleep
and you come back to the images in the
morning and that tends to be
the best use of of uh automation
is using it in that downtime
um and also for you apache um
is there an optimized protocol for
conjugate or primary conjugation
uh of the antibodies yes
okay yes okay yes so with the
the cell dive solution comes the
complete list
of validated antibodies all the
information on sourcing
what the best delusions are conjugation
protocols step by step
walking through how to get the best
results with the standing
there's a question about halo approach
i'm going to leave this to you
um can can halo do segmentation
uh better than just doing a ring around
the nucleus
so is it possible to identify the
cytoplasm is not just a nuclear state
absolutely yes so i will
defer more detailed questions on halo 2
indica labs who are prepared to work
with
our cell dive users but
yes certainly you can do better
segmentation than that
great and uh also for your project in
the uh
commercial implementation what are what
objective do you use
usually use for the imaging uh of the
sample
you typically use a 20x
yeah do you know dna numerical aperture
i do and now i'm going to get myself
confused with the coverslip and
non-coverslip
0.45 yeah okay thank you
uh so uh thank you very much um uh
we're about out of time for questions so
i think we need to move along but
um uh any final comments you might have
fiona or prachee
thank you for your time yeah uh
so thank you for your time today and
your important research we'd also like
to thank lab roots our spa and our
and saitiva for underwriting today's
educational
webcast before we go i'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today
they're interesting questions
questions that we did not have time to
answer
but we're submitted on demand um we'll
be addressing
and we will get back to you by email i
would like to again thank
dr fiona gente and ms pratchett baguetto
for their time
we'd also like to thank labroops for
helping today's broadcast
the broadcast can be viewed on demand uh
lab roots will be sending via email
a link to bill so you can replay it i
know there are some people
on the far east who are having
difficulties with connectivity today
i think this allows you to hear the
seminar in its totality
thank you very much have a pleasant day
we look forward to talking to you again
goodbye